Haven't said much about the process by which light is applied to the surfaces.
One class of methods is to use some form of global illumination algorithm, such
as path tracing. Another technique is called ambient occlusion, which is more
concerned with the geometry in the scene. Instead of percolating light through
the world, ambient occlusion techniques look for crevices, valleys, and other
areas where light is less likely to penetrate. Here's a simple example of
ambient occlusion. This particular form stores at each vertex how that vertex
is in a corner or crevice. These values are then interpolated across each cube
face and blended in. One last thing I should mention. There is a class of
algorithms for interactive rendering called screen space ambient occlusion or
SSAO. While just an approximation, this effect can look quite convincing and is
widely used.